at three o'clock in the morning I don't
know he was second meter ghetto at first
the setup for this is that is that his
limo driver says he's got to stop
somewhere so he stops in the ghetto and
it's David together with a limo that's
it but the thing is that you do exactly
what a donkey would do in the ghetto you
put the joke starts out at minute
limousine I knew he was tame to get on
cuz I'm looking out the window my gun
store gun stores so okay there's a
little statement but it's not preachy
it's not but I'm just painting the
picture
I'm paint a picture right then we get to
the ghetto that was in Washington I saw
some kids running around playing and I
was like who has their kids just running
out on the streets like this this baby
could be in trouble he might need my
help I got to do something but I wasn't
gonna get out the car okay true story
now
did the baby talk to me no was he
selling weed no what I was making a
point and Here I am a black man in a
limousine now we're getting to the class
issues right and together so it's it's
truth ingest I pride myself on saying
real that people don't even notice I'm
saying but they feel it because when
people come up to me they they say that
I love I love that up they can feel it
but I don't think they really know so
when you pointed that out I was very
impressed me was your early comedy
autobiographical and if yes but never
directly I don't want to give away my
secret recipe wanna know what happened
to me
[Music]
he's breaking it in on the new season of
the Chappelle show the Dave Chappelle
show
reports say Chappelle received fifty
five million dollars
[Applause]
like shit on TV know if Chappelle
supposedly had it all a fifty million
dollar contract from Comedy Central a
hit TV show
best-selling DVDs in on April 28th of
last year Dave abruptly walked away not
only from the set of the show but from
fifty million dollars which he left his
fans shocked and most everyone
completely puzzled how could one of the
most promising comedians of recent
history have left a successful
television series
how could he have walked away from a 50
million dollar contract start theme the
story I'm when I'm walking up straight a
bit like Dave that's right you tell it
how it is not really what it feels like
I'll tell you what happened and I can't
say it directly there's a book to me
that encapsulates my entire experience
before I left the show and the book is
called him written by a black American
who was a pimp in the forties he
describes in detail how these men break
women so that they will give them the
money that they make with their own
bodies because when you're a guy that
generates money yeah people have a
vested interest in controlling there's a
story in here so cold it makes me
shudder to think about it well Iceberg
Slim is trying to control the woman that
he finds uncontrollable I will go to
work on the show and I felt awful every
day I felt like some kind of prostitute
or someone I feel so bad why I keep
showing up to this place so he asked
older pimp how I can rein her in and the
older pimp says oh that's easy iceberg
all you have to do is beat that bitch
with a coat hanger I feel like you know
in a lot of instances I was deliberately
being put through stress and then run or
ban and give us some pills they were
trying to get me to take psychotic
medication she'll be so grateful that
you fixed her that she'll forget you
were the motherfucker that beat her in
the first place I forgot the hostility
of the environment of show
maybe there's something else going on
maybe these rapes aren't even the worst
of it wouldn't that be something
wouldn't it be something now the end of
this book iceberg slim tells a story
it's kind of the crescendo of the book
iceberg Slim's bottom bitch is at the
end of a mileage
she was bubbling you could see it she
was going crazy he had to let it go it's
hard to let it go a bottom bitch go and
he wasn't ready to let it go because his
organization couldn't handle losing her
the dvds released and it sets all these
incredible records you know what like
Comedy Central was a hot place to be
when I showed up he said okay there's a
guy in a hotel across the street it's
waiting for you in room number seven we
should go over there I want you fuck him
but before you do I need you to put some
of his stuff in his drink I slipped a
small vial of mineral oil into her palm
I told her it was chlorohydrate only two
drops were not to suck out I did
everything but they made him look right
some wrong daddy leave me something
wrong bitch did you put that stuff in
his drink she said I did everything you
said daddy I put all of it in his drink
he's awaiting him in a bitch wait a
minute you put all of it in his drink I
knelt beside him blocking her view with
my back
I wiped my brow and turned my face to
order my eyes were wide and alarm I said
baby he's dead I think
all right vision me think I can fix this
for you she squeezed tightly against me
I kept telling her she had nothing to
worry about
after all we were together for life and
her secret would always be safe with me
she found out about the hoax years later
that's how the whole shit works ladies
you understand this bitch was at the end
of the mileage she was at 498 she ended
up tricking for iceberg for another six
months she must turn another two hundred
tricks for him do you understand
the whore that they turn this into I've
jumped on that plane and left my
father's bedside which I regret to this
day and I went out and I sat with these
people in this room you got to make them
up hard and fast to stick them for the
long scratch quit so slim be as sweet as
the scratch no sweeter and always stick
a hole for a bundle before you sex er a
hole ain't nothing but a trick to a pimp
this whole dave chappelle thing is gonna
end but i feel like i'm gonna be some
kind of parable by either what you're
supposed to do with what you're not
suppose I'm gonna be something I'm
either gonna be a legend or just that
tragic story but I'm going full-throttle
going all the way I want I'm eager to
find out hi this is will resolve itself
the idea of being courageous is that
even though you're scared you just do
the right thing anyway so in 2004 I
walked away from fifty million dollars
and in November I made a deal for 60
million dollars are you having fun this
time around I am making a point to have
fun too Stan you are yes
[Music]
this video took tons of editing tricks
to carefully assembled these interviews
in a seamless way if I didn't know a
handful of shortcuts it would have taken
significantly longer and I would have
wasted tons of time the best way to get
started on any editing software it's
definitely a tutorial that will teach
you how to edit efficiently like the
high quality tutorials on Skillshare
Skillshare has over 20,000 classes on
everything from photography to business
and that includes a Final Cut Pro class
that goes over the fine details of
editing the first 500 people to click on
the link in the description below can
get two months of completely free access
to Skillshare that includes video
editing tutorials and thousands of
others in financing photography and
cinematography thanks for watching